good morning believe nation today's
message is allow people to help over to
you Aaron Paul I had so many ups and
downs so many struggles so much
rejection but to me I never saw myself
going home and and to be honest uh the
first time I ever asked my parents for
any sort of financial help which was so
hard for me to ask him for this is my
dream it's not their dream of course
they want their you know they want to
see their son succeed in their dreams
but first time I asked them for any sort
of help was right before booking
breaking bad i was like could you help
me with my rent and they paid my rent
three months in a row which was so hard
for me to allow them to do so and it was
so hard for them to do it you know they
had nothing and then I book Breaking Bad
and you know the rest is history so I
see two kinds of people in the world
often there are the moochers and the
moochers of the people who don't work
they just mooch off of other people and
they're more than willing to ask for
help then you've got the people are
actually trying to build something after
you trying to make a name for themselves
after trying to make a difference and
quite often those kinds of people are
afraid to reach out and ask for help and
I get the idea that you don't want to
ask your parents or your your family for
help I get that you know there's a
feeling like you want to make it on your
own I went through that same thing when
I had my first software company you know
I was feeling and sucking and making no
money and my parents and had success in
different fields and I could have used
them and said hey can you help make an
introduction that connections me but I
felt like I wanted to do it all on my
own and I had nobody to help me no
friends and the first you know company I
went to was actually a bank because I
figured hey bankers are supposed to help
entrepreneurs right and went to go meet
my bank manager and asked if he could
help me and so I think people who are
trying to do something important are
often too afraid to ask for help but
it's important because asking for help
can get you where you need to go and a
lot of people who don't ask for enough
help end up failing and struggling
quitting having to go back and get a job
and never realizing their dreams you
can't do this alone you need to be able
to reach out and ask people for their
help so I hope that message sticks with
you today and you find somebody that you
can reach out to to help you build your
business and take it to the next step so
my question is a for you today is who
have you reached out to and gotten some
great help from I'd love to hear the
story leave it in the comments below and
I think that by sharing that it can help
inspire other people to also reach out
to their network and try to get help for
their business thank you for watching
continue to believe have an amazing day
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso oh I lost
money down my shirt look laughs okay
we'll leave it there we'll leave it
there okay question the day it's really
hard talking without moving my neck I am
a robot more money is falling down the
shirt it's stuck on my chest holy care
still more in there it's raining money
holy crap